live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing actual
relationships open phones here at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
christina ellis number one best-selling
author and ramsey personality
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions open phones triple eight eight
two five 825-5225 stevens in mount
pleasant iowa hi stephen how are you
i'm good dave uh first i want to say
thanks for everything you do
we spent just over two weeks in the nicu
and if i had to worry about money while
i was there i don't know what i would
have done oh my goodness
nicu is both the most glorious and scary
uh experience you can have at the same
time isn't it yeah it was
the 15 days was the longest three years
of my life yeah you don't you don't know
you don't believe there's angels on
earth maybe you just need to visit the
people working in there
yeah they were all real great but um so
out of the question um we found out that
my little girl
has down syndrome
and
some of these kids are able to go off to
college and
some of them aren't and we won't know
her abilities
until she's closer to that age and we
didn't know what the best way to save
for her colleges
[Music]
or her future i guess yeah
okay
uh in your name
just just keep building mutual funds in
your name and you can just have
one or two mutual funds that are just
nicknamed uh little girls college fun
but they're in your name okay and you're
in control of it and you're it's just
gonna be a taxable event um but uh and
then you've got all kinds of choices
because you can do whatever you need to
do or want to do
okay
i don't want to put them into an account
that if she is if her abilities are
uh borderline functional okay like she
is functional but barely
and someone could take advantage of her
and all of a sudden 500 000 bucks drops
into her name at 21 years old nah don't
want that
okay right
uh and so any and if she's if she's
really doing great
and she's going to be able to uh you
know be independent
then um
then you can move some money into her
name once you know that like you said it
when she's in her 20s or whatever that's
okay
you'll be able to do that but i i'm just
going to keep control of it
in her best interest
okay
the other thing you're going to do
is um
you're going to set up in your will a
special needs trust
that is formed upon the death of both
you and your wife
okay and the money that goes into that
trust is set up to take care of her the
rest of her life
okay and you name a beneficiary she's
the beneficiary and you name a a trustee
to manage that you give detailed
instructions on how you want that money
handled and i'm guessing you don't have
a half million dollars to plump down in
that today if you died so you're going
to assign part of your term life
insurance to that special needs trust
all right
so the beneficiary of your current some
of your current term insurance is going
to be changed
uh to where like a half million bucks or
something drops in there whatever
whatever the figure is
up only upon your death right and the
death of your spouse so
so it's really the contingent
beneficiary is what amounts to on your
life insurance you have
your wife would probably be your
beneficiary
but in the event of both of your deaths
who gets it
and that's where you would split it up
so in our case we didn't have special
needs kids but just minor children we
had a family trust that would have been
formed when we had minor children upon
both of our deaths uh and it that family
trust had a name as a part of the will
and it was the contingent beneficiary so
sharon was the beneficiary on my life
insurance but if both of us died in a
you know plane wreck or whatever then
the contingent beneficiary goes to end
of that trust to be taking care of the
minor kids the only difference in that
trust and your special needs trust is
your special needs trust will go
throughout the entire life of your
daughter where the minor children's
trust would have just been until they
reached whatever age we wanted to
release it to them as adults okay so
this one's more in perpetuation
than a traditional family trust is that
makes sense
yes sir yeah so get your wills done and
laid out get get the contingent
beneficiary where you're funding the
care of her
and then later on
you know uh 20 years from now you may
have just the money in a mutual fund and
you say this mutual fund funds her
special needs trust and you don't need
life insurance assigned to it does that
make sense
yes but that way she's got care
perpetually
the financial care she'll need
and of course you're going to arrange
other custodial issues as well depending
on uh you know how she progresses how
she develops so
uh you have you have a rare privilege my
friend
um
down's kids are an incredible joy
they are
i've never met uh one wasn't just the
sweetest person on the planet big ol
hearts yeah hey dave in a situation like
this would it be wise if he has other
kids to potentially save in a 529 as
well since it can be transferred to
siblings
you could yeah you could and you're the
custodian so you're controlling that
that that that might even be a better
plan i didn't think of that or just an
option
the other thing is the problem is the
529 is um
we transfer the other siblings but it
has to be used for education and we
haven't
let's say that she doesn't go to school
but still needs the money yeah you can't
get it out of the 529 for that that's
true so you gotta i'm gonna i'm just
gonna keep it in my name but that's a
that's a valid strategy
but the problem is you can't access it
if something hap if if she doesn't go to
school and she is gonna need
financial support right
perpetually of some kind because uh
depending on again the the severity of
what she's facing on the development
side but um wow wow
wow
all right open phones a triple eight
eight two five
five
two two
five
that's a reminder for everyone uh
listening if you don't have your will
you get a well done
yes
and it's also so good he's being such a
great dad thinking about this early and
making a plan i know
obviously coming out of the nicu and
going through everything you just did is
pretty traumatic and intense and just
that's a great way to channel that
energy thinking through you know how are
we going to walk this out how are we
going to set her up for success in the
best way possible yeah exactly it's a
um you know start start planning and
laying all that out and then that
relieves that
portion of your brain that worries about
those things don't worry about that i
can now concentrate on just her care
right and her development just being her
dad because i don't have that's done one
less thing you know four scum thing one
less thing one less thing one less thing
to worry about because you did it
because you checked the box you got it
done and
i got to tell y'all
the wealthy people that i meet
that have immense financial peace in
their wealth they're not dysfunctional
they do detailed estate plans
and it's it's a because you want to keep
the government's hands off of it be so
that the money that you've worked so
hard for goes the direction you think is
best
and see
one less thing yeah one last thing to
think about i don't think about it
anymore box checked
there you go this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
still on baby step number one
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
how many times have you found yourself
saying one day
when you're thinking about a goal you
have one day i'll be able to buy a house
one day i'll be happy with my career one
day i won't have to battle with anxiety
uh
that's called kicking the can down the
road boys and girls stop waiting around
whatever your one day is let's get with
it
that's why we created smart conference
smart conference is the one day event
oddly enough where we tackle all areas
of your life and guys let's face it we
could all use that kind of boost right
now you're gonna hear from the nation's
top
thought leaders
on money
career mental health
relationships
marriage
leadership
the event is hitting the road will be in
dallas texas on saturday october 22nd it
is 64
sold out
that means if you want a ticket you
should get one before they're gone
this is a limited commodity
the platinum is sold out the vip is sold
out uh general access passes are 39
these are best-selling authors
world-class speakers number one
best-selling authors like rachel cruz dr
john delony ken coleman george campbell
christina ellis to my right i'll be
speaking uh craig and amy groschel from
life church will be talking about
marriage and uh this is a world-class
event this is an event that i sit in the
audience and take notes
i want to hear what these people have to
say about their given areas
and uh it'll be about six or eight
thousand folks in the arena it will be
booming it's gonna be a day long event
you will leave it's a smart conference
so you will leave smarter
gonna work this is your first one to do
it's my first one my first ramsay live
event all right so how nervous are you
for that oh gosh
i mean you get nervous you don't seem
nervous on stage six to eight thousand
people that's a lot of people
there's no more than 800 i mean it's the
same you spoke in front of staff meeting
the other day that's 1200 people
you weren't nervous at all
if you were if you were your cool hand
luke i'm just saying
good nobody knew
i like that i was standing on stage
beside you i didn't know you're nervous
if you were nervous but i i think i
think it's going to be great and we're
excited to have you join the lineup it's
going to be very very good so get your
tickets ramsey solutions dot com
slash events ramsey solutions dot com
slash events
do not miss this folks
a lot of times you need your batteries
charged let me just tell you what
happens here okay
this is not just information
information doesn't fix your life
inspiration does not fix your life
inspiration without solid information is
just a wisp in the wind right it's just
gone information without inspiration is
boring as crud
and you won't activate on it you have to
put the two together so you're gonna
laugh all day long you're gonna hear
great storytelling all day long you're
going to hear world-class communicators
that know how to take information and
inspiration weave them together and
cause you to come cause you leave there
and activate and that's that's what this
is about and the other thing that
happens that people have forgotten about
and they kinda
should remember after the pandemic
shutdown the economic shutdown
uh you remember when we were flattening
the curve and now we have no idea why we
did that but yeah you know i remember
that
and so um
yeah people all being in the room all
ready to learn all ready to do something
they uh there's energy that comes off of
that that's very real and it's like
going to your favorite sporting event
right you go you know go watch your
football team and everybody's cheering
you leave
energized from that and this is the only
difference is you're not cheering for
someone else's success here you're
cheering for your success
and it's
it's exhilarating it really is our
question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey and you'll get the best possible
deal today's question comes from katie
in mississippi i'm a women's basketball
coach at a large college the topic of
financial literacy came up in
conversation with one of our freshmen
yesterday our team of 18 to 23 year olds
is in a unique position to graduate with
no student debt they get monthly
scholarship checks additional cost of
attendance money academic incentive
money and whatever deals they acquire
some of these young ladies are making
serious bank and i'd love to set them up
to succeed do you have any insights that
would help our players maximize their
financial opportunities during their
college years
i love that question
well i think just the fact that you're
already talking about this is awesome
you know so many students in college
they don't have conversations with
adults about money i know that's
shocking it seems like we use it every
day we should have these conversations
but i hear it all the time why did no
one tell me about these basic financial
concepts and how to prepare myself for
the future so the fact that you are
having this conversation right now and
wanting to set them up for success is
huge lean into that now of course we
talk about budgets a lot around here so
just even helping them set up a budget
because a lot of these students you said
they're making bank that's a lot of
money for
18 to 23 year olds to deal with and
figure out so helping them figure out
what budget is you know get them set up
with every dollar or budgeting app and
help them figure out where that money
needs to go also an emergency fund is
always going to be useful if they can
start having that money set up as a you
know aside for any emergencies that pop
up i know a lot of their stuff is
covered right now but
especially as a college athlete things
can happen you know they could get
injured there could be
you know for some reason they could lose
a scholarship or a deal so having that
money set aside while it's fruitful
right now is going to be great and then
of course talking about their future
help them understand why it's important
to not just spend that money right now
like it's great that it's coming in but
why is it important to save you know why
is it important to build your emergency
fund and then you know as they get
towards graduation thinking about do
they want to get a master's degree you
know they need to start thinking about
retirement do they want to buy a house
so helping them cast that vision at this
point in their lives is going to be so
helpful
yeah absolutely if you're smart you'll
have them you'll call and have christina
ellis come speak to him
um and that'll be a good basis for
kicking this off uh the
uh i'm not coming but she would and so
um the uh um my my calendar's just
completely blown up already through
about this time next year but the uh
but it's important that you get
information in front of them and you
might put them through financial peace
university but at the end of the day if
you can somehow through some
process you teaching them as a coach
um
and
you know just pull them aside and go
okay today we're doing an hour and we're
going to talk about this but the
principles are this
what we don't want
and it's the problem with the with the
nio money that's going on uh it's it
i've talked to several uh head football
coaches have already contacted me that
are friends of mine in d1 and they got
kids getting you know a million bucks
three million bucks five million bucks
in d1 football and i doubt girls
basketball is getting that much but they
may be getting something uh with the nil
monies out there the name image and
likeness money that's available is it's
uh they went from college athletes
couldn't get five dollars to now they're
millionaires you know and it's just nuts
so um and and they're scared the coaches
are athletic directors across the nation
are scared to death
the damage this is going to do to these
kids
it should be a blessing but i mean just
look at an nfl player
and you can you know what do you got 78
of them are bankrupt
within four years of leaving the league
78 is that bizarre
that's bizarre wow no that's not right
78 are disabled the bankruptcy rate is
4x the national average it's four times
you're four times more likely to go
bankrupt if you're an nfl player than
the average person dang that's painful
and because what they do they they do
stupid on steroids they get money coming
out their ears and they go bananas
and if you can't do it at 23 years old
when you're a second round draft pick
you sure as crap can't do it when you're
18 years old
without somebody coming alongside you
putting their arm around your shoulder
and kicking your little butt
and that's what needs to happen here and
lovingly this coach is asking that in a
very nice way she cares about her
students welfare and that's great what a
great coach so thank you katie for being
that person now here's what i would tell
them if you can get if you can get this
through their little heads
they got a chance okay
they need to lay out a game plan where a
percentage
formula is applied to every dollar that
comes in
i'm going to set aside x for generosity
y percent for a future investment and z
percent for spending
and i'm not gonna spend more than the
amount i set aside so you give them some
money doing spend and enjoy the money
that they're making
but the vast majority of it is invested
and set aside for their future and that
way they don't wake up at 32 years old
and want to kick their little 18 year
old self's butt later
and so that that's god man
so yeah you've got to have them lay out
some boundaries so they don't live with
that horrible taste of regret in the
back of their tongue the rest of their
life this is the ramsey shop
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
christina ellis number one best-selling
author ramsey personalities my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five in the lobby
of ramsey solutions jazz and cassie are
with us hey guys welcome hi dave how are
you doing good to have you guys where do
you all live
we live in fresno california oh great
cool welcome to nashville and all the
way here to do a debt-free scream how
much have you paid off
we've paid off 446 thousand dollars cool
wow and how long did this take it's
about nine and a half years very cool
and your range of income during that
time we went starting at about 150 000
and then up to about 265.
very cool what do y'all do for a living
he's a bus driver
and i'm an engineer civil engineer huh
very good good
so nine and a half years
446 000 is that your house yes you paid
off your house
your weirdos
way to go weirdos i love you dave we did
something more weird than that what'd
you do we paid off two houses two outs
well you're double weirdos okay what's
the other one a rental or a rental house
okay very cool so what's this house
worth
so our house right now is worth about
six hundred thousand dollars our primary
house and then we have the rental that's
paid for as well we have a second rental
that uh what we inherited so that was a
booster what are they worth they're
about four hundred thousand so just in
real estate alone you're millionaires
yes sir
how much in investments and investments
it's about a half a million and 1.5 in
real estate okay excellent
love you
amazing all right somewhere around a
decade ago you learned something about
the ramsey way how did you get connected
to the ramsey way it was uh through my
dad and um
and it's hard for me because in 2016 he
passed away uh my dad was 100 blind uh
he was hit and killed by a car but i
could still remember when we first
started this dave ramsey plan
uh my dad uh went being a city bus
railroad was running buses and i had
split shifts and so when i would go uh
to their house during the split shift he
would have dave ramsey play on the am
station i'd be like
dad turn that stuff off i'm trying to
hear all that turn that off and so about
five years happened of that and it's all
god's timing where uh i heard something
that caught my attention and from that
point forward we started just you know
we were uh i was all in at the time yeah
okay i remember what it was
do you remember what it was to caught
your attention no i wish i did a lot of
people have asked me that okay all right
sorry about that cassie what were you
gonna say yeah i was just gonna say i
was slower to the table it was like who
is this dave guy living in her house i
do not know who he is i don't even like
him
what is happening i make good money i
want to spend spend spend but it was it
was contagious and uh financial peace
university was the game changer for me
went and attended at my church and was
just encouraged that everybody was there
trying to make their life better and
it's it's definitely been life-changing
and i
i can't say enough about that program
and just how it brought me to the table
to really um support my husband and be
in it all all in yeah all in at that
moment well that's definitely the way to
learn the ramsey way now the uh
uh how long ago did you go through
financial peace university it was about
nine and a half years old that's when it
kicks the whole thing off yeah yeah well
that's the final bow then and then here
we go game on that's right okay very
cool what's the name of your church it's
cross city christian church in fresno
very good cool okay so once you all are
on this journey there's a little bit of
hesitation to start but once you were on
it you were on it what did it look like
what did you all do to get out of debt
um well the way it started for us we
were already doing smart things with our
money we were already on baby steps four
five and six
and so
from listening to the show i see so many
people talk about gazelle intensity and
baby step two and i wanted to feel that
and so what we did was be pretty much
gazelle intense
and where we made uh like david bob
talks in his book automatic millionaire
about making everything automatic
that's what we did and we set aside 5
000
a month for 54 months to knock out our
house and then we were comfortable and
but the key for us was making everything
automatic yeah that's awesome did people
think you were crazy
uh yeah um some did and some just oh
that's nice that's that then that's
that's the thing that you're doing
that's good good for you guys
yeah i love that you just went gazelle
intends to get this house paid off that
is a lot of money in real estate y'all
that's amazing what he didn't say is he
worked all day every day for a very long
time so we didn't see him so that we
could do all of that and it was hard it
was hard you know people going on
vacation people buying new cars i had
the same van for 12 years it's like uh
i'm tired of this man i want a new van
was it worth it it was so worth it it
was so worth it and we would do it all
over again and and a heartbeat was it
worth all the extra shifts jazz yeah one
of the things was uh i averaged several
30 days 60 days straight uh my record
was 86 days straight and it was a good
thing i love what i do i love the people
there it was it was a great experience
but you got to have your why in front of
you and when you have that why we have
lots of we had a poster board where we
set our goals for the house originally
and then for the second house we set up
a rice and beans like a thermometer jar
that we could visually see yeah and when
you set those type of goals make a
visual it's life-changing to where it
forces you not to quit and hold yourself
accountable especially when your kids
are watching you yeah
for all the people who think you know i
could never pay my house off that's
that's an unattainable dream what would
you tell those people is the key to
getting completely out of debt
uh i would say the key to getting out of
debt is uh
a lot of people that i like to be
coachable teachable to and i teach this
plan to people is i tell them
if you want to lose weight you go to a
basically a physical gym to get
physically fit well in the financial
world then you should be going to a
financial gym and that's where i go to
the financial gym dave ramsey podcast
and listen to dave ramsey's show and
listen to other self-help or also read
self-help and spiritual based books to
keep yourself focused because you got to
stay strong and stay committed because
the people that i've seen around me in
this 10-year period that
the majority of them that quit stopped
watching the show stopped doing the
things that got them to where they were
heading that right direction so that's
key i believe yeah you guys played all
the way through
pretty cool now you don't have a single
payment
in the world
how's that feel
amazing uh definitely freedom like no
other i have people that i know we all
know that struggle
and it's it's just a freedom like you
can't explain you don't have to worry
about during the pandemic you didn't
have to worry about what happens what's
going to happen if we you know lose our
job and it it just
brings a a piece that is just
indescribable
yeah i don't think you can
i mean we try to talk about it and try
to help people visualize how it feels
and so forth but but there is something
that happens when that last payment goes
out and you go we're done yeah there's
just you just kind of have this moment
it's a physical reaction for a lot of
people
and me it was so way to go y'all way to
go i'm proud of you yeah excellent
excellent job baby steps millionaires
along the way 100 debt free times two
yeah and two houses yeah you did two of
everything didn't you so
good good stuff guys very very well done
very well done so uh we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you the book
we got a copy of total money makeover
for you and the way you guys are uh
talking about this and evangelizing out
there you're gonna let people know about
it and we'll give you a one-year
membership to financial peace university
the new one uh with the new videos with
dr john delony rachel cruz george
campbell me it's the best videos we've
done on that course right now and so uh
but you can give that away and you guys
are givers i can tell you're going to be
able to help a lot of people as you talk
about this and plug in we'll hand all
that off to you all right bring the
kiddos up let's introduce them get their
names and ages
so this is our son zachary he's 16.
and this is malaya she's 12. all right
very good very good good job guys
excellent i think the other thing dave
that we didn't mention is knowing that
we're setting these guys up on the right
path that that's the other thing that's
just very encouraging as a parent
to know that
these guys know that debt is not okay
and not to get themselves in in those
types of situations and this kiddo when
he was in kindergarten said
that there was some kid talking about a
credit card and he he got in trouble i
got a call from the office saying your
son said credit cards are stupid he used
the s word and i said well i can't
really get him in trouble for that right
so
we taught our son to speak the truth
i said just you know just maybe use a
different word
yeah well maybe not that was pretty that
was pretty descriptive yeah
all right jazz and cassie
way to go guys fresno california 446 000
paid off baby steps millionaires times
two nine and a half years making 150 to
265 count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
to god be the glory three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
that is how it's done
this is the ramsey shaft
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christina ellis number one best-selling
author ramsey personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us america
ben is with us ben is in charlotte north
carolina hi ben how are you
good are you better than i deserve
what's up
yeah so i just had a quick question for
you and um that is
i'm getting a lot of financial aid
refund money and i was wondering if i
should go ahead and start paying off
student loans with that money
are you out of school
no sir i'm a senior and um
i finished getting my undergrad
where is this refund money coming from
did you get a bunch of scholarships this
year
yeah so i got around six thousand
dollars in scholarship and then i also
got married
two months ago
so we got about
we got around ten thousand a piece
um
as well
okay and the six thousand in
scholarships um is that being used to
cover tuition or tuition
already
yeah so the um
my tuition is actually only uh 3 900
per semester so they split it up between
the two and i'll be getting like uh 49
or 4 700 back in uh per semester
okay and how much money in student loans
do you have right now
um so my wife's the one that student
loans and she only has eleven thousand
and the only reason i even uh
was calling twos because i know that the
uh 2000 of it is unsubsidized and i know
that that accrues over
um
like while you're still in school the
interest accrues on that and i know
there was a stop on it until august 31st
has she graduated
uh no sir she graduates with me next may
as well okay all right what are you
studying
um i'm actually doing accounting good
what about your wife
she's doing graphic design good okay
great good job
all right how are you all paying for
your expenses right now because i know a
lot of times that refund money is built
into your package to pay for you know
room and board and meals um do you all
have jobs like how are you paying for
your living expenses so right now i'm an
intern at a local accounting firm up in
my school um that's actually about the
end i'm about to actually pick up
another job um she's a server at chili's
and that's what both are going to be
doing during the school year
i love that good for you guys well done
all right so here's the thing
the 12 the uh i'm sorry the 10 months we
have until you graduate in may
um
mathematically doesn't matter on
interest accruing
okay
what does matter is a brand new marriage
a senior year in school
and making sure that we get out of
school with no debt
and so what i would do is park all the
cash
to the side
in a simple savings account and forget
it's there
and work your way and scholarship your
way through the remainder of the year if
you end up with more cash just pile it
up over there
when you both graduate and land your
jobs
in may june
and now we're setting off uh we're
changing we're transitioning from
college years to
uh
to to the adult game then
right
when you make that transition and you
have those jobs and that money's coming
in now you set your new budget up and
then you pull the money out of that
account and you pay those student loans
off that day
okay so one year from today
okay pay them off then and in the
meantime that cash that big pile of cash
here's what it gives you
and number one it's an insurance policy
that you're going to finish school with
no more debt
agreed
no matter what happens you can make it
with no doubt we know that okay now the
trick is to maximize
your other stuff and not use any of it
so that that money is free and clear
next summer
okay but number one it's an insurance
policy here's the thing that
you should get from it if both of you
are in agreement on this
you both should
get a a level of stress a level of
anxiety
removed because you're sitting on twenty
five thirty thousand dollars over there
it'll allow you to go
and that's a really cool thing to do in
your first year marriage
i have your back against the wall with
somebody pointing a gun at your face
right
yes sir and this this is that relaxing
thing and there's so there's a
relational benefit you're going to study
better you're going to work better at
chili's you're going to everything's
gonna be better because you don't have
money worries yes oh what a relief what
a strong foundation to start on and what
a great job you all have done yeah
they're impressive and i love that his
story highlights something that i think
a lot of people don't realize about
scholarships so a lot of people think
scholarships just cover tuition that if
you cover tuition that's all you need
but most schools lay out their cost of
attendance which includes everything you
need to go to school meals books housing
transportation expenses and you can get
scholarships all the way up to cost of
attendance therefore you can get it to
cover things like meals books and it'll
come in the form of a refund check like
he is getting a check cut to him by the
school to pay for those other expenses
so it's really great to go for
scholarships because it can pay for some
of those outside expenses you can't go
over the cost of attendance so you can't
just win a bunch of scholarship money
and go buy a car with it but it will
cover your living expenses as well if
you get enough scholarship money yeah
excellent well done well done well done
what's up guys
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five dan's in atlanta
georgia hey dan what's up
dude hello hey how can we know okay
wife and i are going to have 800 000
on the 29th of this month i hate it when
that happens
yeah
sale of our home that we had paid off we
doubled our money in 24 months on that
home good lord so we feel very blessed
um
we bankrolled three college educations
over the last few years
um so we don't have a lot in retirement
only about 40 k
so the idea was we're going to downsize
a little bit maybe build or buy
no more than 500k
and then have the extra 300.
um just kind of want to know if that
that makes sense or should we be
thinking should we not buy it all should
we rent just kind of want to get your
feedback no you should buy and that
sounds like a good number
i like your number what's your household
do you like that yeah what's your
household income uh
it's a hundred right now david um i uh i
originate mortgages so right now
you know when things stay the same the
way they are right now there's no refi
business yep uh and with my agent
business you know our our household
income is going to probably drop to 70.
i'm guessing yeah that would be awesome
at least yeah
yeah so
with that in mind uh you think half
million is okay yeah you're paying
cash oh yeah absolutely yeah if you're
paying cash for it
and that leaves you 300 to sit down with
your smartvestor pro with the 300 and
you know start some good mutual fund
investing
how about some residual income maybe a
little two hundred thousand dollar fixer
that can be an airbnb or a renter what
are your thoughts on that be fine that's
gonna leave me a hundred in the bank
that's fine
you know your real estate your real
estate people but i wouldn't run my pro
forma out based on airbnb
uh
i would run it i would run it out based
on a rental if you want to run the
airbnb that's fine but that's
unrealistic that's not sustainable long
term
for a lot of reasons uh number one
there's a lot of markets that are
shutting down airbnbs with zoning
changes and law changes yeah uh and the
other thing
hoa2 yeah hoas are shutting them down
it's it's you know it's really
tight that market's tightening up and
the second thing is it's a complete pain
in the butt
because you're dealing with a new tenant
every 20 minutes
you know and so you make a lot of money
but the hassle factor of it is
legitimately a problem
so you know you can go make some money
for a few years with it but you're gonna
get tired of it and rent it
so uh i think um let me tell you how
many airbnbs i own zero just for that
reason okay i don't know there's good
money in it you can do it but it's a
complete it's a lot of work you run a
hotel
so i mean it's like real work and stuff
so it's not you said passive there ain't
nothing passive about it it's not
passive income at all it's active income
so i mean technically
from a tax standpoint you could call it
that but it's very active so yeah go
ahead and do that but buy it based on
the fact of what you can rent it for
because someday you're going to end up
doing that but yeah if you want to do
real estate instead of mutual funds fine
with me i do i do a lot of real estate
especially as heads into his retirement
years running an airbnb does not sound
like the most relaxing thing to do
i mean you can do it but it's
it's a lot of work it's work yeah it's
it's um
there you go that puts us our the ramsey
show in the books
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
christina ellis number one best-selling
author ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five maggie is
with us in washington d.c hi maggie how
are you
hi dave i'm good how are you better than
we deserve what's up
um so i just um my husband and i are
trying to figure out we're in baby step
two and we're trying to figure out if we
should
trade in two of our cars um for um
or used cars that would um be like you
know a lot more
cost effective so we could get rid of
our car payment it was hard to let that
come out of your mouth wasn't it
yeah
right now
i listen to you every single day and
it's surreal
[Laughter]
so uh all right tell us about tell us
about the cars car number one what do
you owe on it what is it worth
okay so it's a volkswagen atlas 2018 um
we owe about 11 000 on it it's worth um
we went to a dealership yesterday we got
them up to 19
on that
and that one was still paint yeah and
that one we're still paying and then the
other one is a 2009 jeep liberty
and that one is paid off
at first they came to us at 2700 i got
them up to five
what is your household income
um it's about 145. how much data
we have eighty one thousand nine hundred
and eighty two left
i would not sell these cars unless you
don't like them
okay
[Applause]
yeah
um i mean the idea was really exciting
because it would expedite the process um
and i'd like to um just knock this out
as soon as i can it's just hanging over
my head every day the debt
um if you told me 81 000 and you had a
30 000 car debt
yeah
yeah but 11 000 of 81 is not your
problem is it
i don't know yeah
well you're still going to need
something to drive and that's not i mean
you'd only have about what eight
thousand you just get rid of the 11 000
in debt and buy a car right
right
yeah exactly exactly um we have three
kids so we're not trying to get like the
oldest car on the block with
driving on the highway and stuff so um
we do like the car the atlas but the
payment it just i feel like it's just
taking a while to get rid of it what's
the rest of the debt
a student loans
um
student loans really yeah how long have
you been working on all this
the ramsey way
so um we started in 2020
and we're making some headway and then
um last year um so at the end of 2020 we
had our third child
um and it um
long story short um it just ended up
being like a very difficult year um i
was in like survival mode um he had a
lot of health issues he just fell off
the wagon
and just didn't do anything
he's a lot better he's still um crazy
but much better health-wise so
he's just our wild one and we're
definitely done now
but
so we've decided to get back on track
and we've paid off about
about 7 000 so far and at the end of
this year we're supposed to have this
card paid off at the end of this year
here's here's what i heard
and you can tell me if i'd if i heard it
wrong
uh
we've just been through
hell and i'm tired
and i'm desperately looking for a
quicker easier way to do this
and i was hoping this was it
yeah
yeah no that's
that's great
and and uh so
the the good news is you get to keep the
car the bad news is because it's not the
problem uh the bad news is now it is
game on girl
yeah now you just the rest of that
garbage is in the rearview mirror most
of it anyway thank goodness sorry you've
been through all that it's hard i mean
it's been a hard year hard couple years
for a lot of us
and emotionally and stress and
everything else and just the whole
the the climate in the culture right now
is just bizarre
so it's just affecting everything but
the uh uh
but yeah i i and i'm sorry you've been
through that here's the trick though
mathematically and actually
90 percent of you getting out of debt is
you guys getting
gazelle intense
on a budget
working the plan
no eating out no vacations no freaking
life and we're going to clean this mess
up you make 145 000 you should be
debt-free in 18 months
that was i was thinking 15 bucks okay
i'll go with 50. i'll go with 15.
and for that you don't sell the car
the car the car accelerates that by one
and a half to two months
right point being it does not solve the
problem
right if it cut the time in half from 18
months to nine months your car sold girl
i'd be throwing it out right now
for you for you right
yeah you guys have a really good shovel
i mean it'd be a bit more concerning if
you didn't have such a high income but
you do have a good shovel to work with
and like dave said you could knock this
out
easily in under two years you could
still live on six figures and knock this
out in two years so it's like if you
guys get gazelle intense you can do that
even faster so um yeah you playing did
you do you playing sports when you're a
kid
uh i know i did cross country okay cross
country taco that's a sport
and so uh you're running what three what
is that a three mile run usually in high
school
yeah usually yeah so the first
mile and a half of your three mile run
you fell twice and skinned your knees
oh and your hands while you're at it
okay now you got the rest of the run
left you're not going to fall in this
part of the run
but
those falls
are are causing you to have to suck it
up and get with it
and and it's hard it's hard to overcome
the pain
of the first half of the race you had a
painful first start on this
and uh you know i think it's just smart
to say it out loud
you know those are legitimate reasons
that you you didn't fall off the wagon
girl you got knocked off the wagon
and it's legitimate pain you felt it
it's real your knees are skinned your
hands are skinned you fell yeah and it's
uh it's okay to say that but what that
means is once you say it out loud you go
and
game on
second half
we got the crap beat out of us in the
first half we're going back in the
second half and take them back i'm going
to take this game back yep i ran cross
country in high school and that speaks
to my heart i mean i just remember the
middle of the race especially if you had
a bad first half feels so disheartening
you're just like oh i don't know if i
can go on but man when you round that
corner and you start getting closer to
the finish line you're going to feel
your spirit lift again you just have to
get through this really hard middle it's
lifting the chin up and looking at that
finish line and reaching for that
instead of gazing in the rearview mirror
and uh it's hard it's emotional
but i'm just saying i'm agreeing with
you it's been difficult but that's all
you're just going to use that as
motivation for the second half
game on
15 months girl i want to hear from you
i'll hear your debt free scream yeah
come see us we're proud of you we love
you get after it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one
dashboard go to netsuite.com ramsey
right now to get their free white paper
jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today with rising costs
everywhere you look we know you've had
enough
right now normal in america is a bit
freaked out
the cash register at the grocery store
the cashier
looking at a gallon of milk like it's a
bar of gold
the overdraft in your bank account
normal sucks you deserve a chance at
some extra breathing room in your budget
so we're gonna
well we're excited to tell you this
month we're gonna give away 500
every week and a grand prize of three
thousand dollars in the ramsey cash
giveaway think about all the things you
could do with some extra money
no purchase is necessary you got to be
18 years old or older to win just go to
ramseysolutions.com giveaway and you can
register every day
ramseysolutions.com
giveaway
ava is with us in roanoke virginia hi
ava welcome to the ramsay show
hi mr ramsey thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up
so in your foundations of personal
finance class you said to negotiate the
price of everything so i was wondering
if there's a way to negotiate the price
of college
ava i love this question how old are you
ava
i'm 16. oh my goodness you sound like me
at 16 and i just absolutely love that
you're calling the show this is
fantastic what do you want to do with
college where do you want to go
i want to go into art and animation
okay what do you hope to do with that
um concept art and like character design
for movies hopefully
that's awesome are you already starting
to look at schools and kind of think
through where you want to attend
i have but i haven't really decided on
any schools yet well you're 16. so you
still have plenty of time i love this
conversation the answer is yes you can
negotiate the price of college but it
does depend on the school so
a lot of people when they go to a
college's website they see that sticker
price and they go i can't pay that and
they automatically assume they can't
attend that school but very few people
actually pay the sticker price that's
listed on the website most colleges have
a tuition discount of some sort a lot of
people don't know that because it's just
wrapped into the financial aid package
that they get they see it as merit
scholarships they see it as financial
aid um but it is a tuition discount now
a lot of people just see their financial
aid package and assume that's all i got
like this is all the school's going to
offer me but you can be one of the few
that actually do go back to the school
and try to negotiate tuition so
it doesn't always happen it depends on
the school i definitely wouldn't count
on it or expect it but you can do it you
can go back and ask them if they can
discount it
and
the best one of the best things you can
do with negotiation
is to have walk away power
and that means that you are not married
to a particular school
we are going shopping boys and girls
where are we going to get the best deal
and uh then then what you do is you tell
that one school you tell school a
that school b's making you a better
offer and they're gonna have to they're
gonna have to pony up if they are i mean
i want you to lie to them but um i mean
you start playing them against each
other you go we have asked you know i'm
applauded i've i've been i'm looking at
four different schools i'm going to go
to the one that gives me the best help
in tuition
are you that school let's find out are
you ready to play spin the wheel you
know and that's get just get them all
playing against each other and uh
there's there's
it's so amazing that all of a sudden
these schools that are uh you know a
little bit snotty they suddenly become
uh like mercenary and want your money
right because at the end of the day you
know they've got budgets they're trying
to recruit students they're trying to
get them in the door so they want your
money they want to make a deal
especially if you're a competitive
student
we actually talked to a company not long
ago
that they actually built a business
around having students upload their
financial aid letters so that they could
compare what kind of discounts they were
getting from the different colleges
which just shocked me to see how many
colleges
they they kind of played this game of
like you know trying to recruit they
were like businesses trying to charge
different amounts for different people
and try to get them to like make deals
and i was like wow that is just crazy
but it was nice that they were trying to
bring transparency to that process so
students could see the price is
negotiable yeah
and and if it's not that's okay but you
have to maintain walk away power
in any negotiation
if you go that's the only house on the
planet you're about to pay too much for
that house
if you go i have to have the green car
and there's only one in the southeast
you're about to pay too much for this
car seriously so this is that kind of
crap will kill you and it'll kill you on
this any negotiation so having options
to play against each other and having
walkaway power
instead of getting all drama cleaned up
about the particular location you're
going to go to school
because you know
the people that make it in the business
that you're going to go into
where they went to school has zero to do
with it it's whether they have talent or
not
so if you're going to do
animation and you want to create
animated characters for movies you know
they nobody cares where you went to
school
they just care can you do it and are you
the best or one of the best have you got
some idea that that makes me want to
make a film if i'm a filmmaker you know
and can you are you the character are
you the person you know can you do this
and so yeah right and at this age i mean
you've got time like you said you don't
know what college you want to attend now
but now is that time to start exploring
and researching different scholarships
at colleges you know you don't want to
get your mind set on one certain school
at this point and then you know get get
offered nothing in scholarships when you
could have potentially found a school
where you could get a full ride so i
love one looking at different options so
you have negotiating power and two you
may not even need to negotiate you may
just get a full ride straight from the
beginning so you know keep those options
open and explore
everything that's out there you know i
think we're going to see more of this
because higher ed is um
they kind of got a pretty big black eye
right now
overcharging causing being part of the
cause of the student loan
debacle epic failure we have in this
country and part of it's driven by these
increasing tuition prices all the time
the second thing is
the those goobers in higher ed you know
what they did
they had everybody go to school from
home online
during covet and they charged them full
freaking price
and people are going wait a minute
i'm not guy this is online
i'm i'm zoomed out i'm not doing this
and so uh a lot of people really a lot
of students and parents of students kind
of got fed up
with the attitudes at higher ed and now
higher ed's trying kind of back on its
heels and it's gonna it's kind of pushed
out it's people are talking about you
don't need to go to college at all and
all college is too expensive which is
not true
but uh you know it's they are they are
in a position they're going to want to
negotiate because they're going to be
trying to get people back in there after
the horrible reputation that they've
developed as a category well and it's
about time i mean this this reckoning
has needed to happen for a while for so
long it's been like education at all
costs and we can always increase it
every year even if students go
1.75 trillion dollars into student loan
debt i mean this the covid crisis
happened along with the student loan
crisis and these two merging together
has just created kind of chaos in higher
education it's fabulous
it gives people a chance to re-evaluate
yeah if the government will keep their
stinking hands out of it and not prop
them up
they're too big to fail no they're not
they're stupid and some of them deserve
to fail
and so you know it's it's gonna wake
them up wake them up here let the
marketplace do what it's supposed to do
and so then you will find a less
expensive
alternative to go get a good education
whether it be a
vo tech thing or whether it be uh a
higher ed you know process i don't care
uh but but you know people are going to
get very practical finally
right and and the the institutions of
learning that do not adjust to the
practicality the utilitarian view
of education are about to lose their
butts right because people are seeing
now just even in the workplace that
there are people who went to public
schools who had no student loan debt you
know they they got a public school
education next to somebody who spent two
hundred thousand dollars and they're
working the exact same job and so it's
like that's great if you can get it paid
for to go to a prestigious school but
you don't have to there's so many
different options and you know do what
you got to do but do it debt-free yeah
and do what she's doing she's thinking
about it ahead of time being intentional
instead of just signing up in october or
signing up in august and going oh wait a
minute i have to have tuition in four
weeks what am i going to do well you
should have thought about that ahead of
time this ain't a friday night party you
planned on your instagram
you know seriously you need to get your
act together this this kid right here
she's got her act together man she's you
you're right i love it you were you were
an overachiever at that age too
i was a i was the portion of the class
that made the top half possible this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis best-selling author and
ramsey personalities my co-host today in
the lobby of ramsey solutions on that
debt free stage tim and luanne are with
us hey guys how are you great
good to have you guys where do you all
live
little rock we're uh actually live in
maumel which is like
a suburb yeah cool welcome to nashville
how much debt have you paid off
222 thousand dollars 807 well 220 2 870
way to go
how long did this take
four years and three months all right
and uh what was your range of income
during that time 152 000 to 178 000.
cool what do y'all do for a living i'm a
computer programmer my wife's a medical
coder perfect good what kind of debt was
this 223 000 oh it ranged from uh a
cabin
an rv
uh cars credit cards irs debt
loans student loans y'all were normal oh
yeah yeah
and you decided to not be normal anymore
sick of it congrat good that's what you
got to get sick of it yeah yeah so i'm
proud of you way to go y'all it's
amazing four years
223 thousand
dollars
wow amazing
so how did this all happen how did you
get decided you're going to go do the
ramsey way well uh
about five years ago i was diagnosed
with prostate cancer and i wrote my wife
a note because i didn't know what would
happen if i had the surgery
and that kind of lit fire under her
and that's how we got started
so women the note says uh surprise were
deeply in debt or what did it say no it
said here's how to take care of the debt
oh my gosh and here's what to pay off
first
on a sticky note and sat it on my desk
and i was like no i'm not doing this
our church happened to be offering fpu
oh good and uh i was like which is
better than a sticky note exactly yeah
exactly
yeah and i said let's let's do this i
had never heard of dave ramsey and
apparently he had i had and he didn't
say anything i figured well if if it was
her idea
then we're going for it yeah
so we did and our coordinators are with
us
today
and then we actually joined them and
coordinated the next class as a duel
and we have been fbu coordinators now
for um this will be our fifth season oh
my goodness thank you yeah wow well one
thing about that when you are leading a
class you have to do the stuff exactly
because you're totally a hypocrite
exactly exactly it makes you it makes
you stay on the straight and narrow oh
yeah yeah and uh and it does remind you
and inspire you the people around you oh
yeah right yeah because some of the
people come through these classes they
do some amazing things right right and
another thing was that my wife was
saying we're never going to retire we're
going to just keep working at our desk
and we'll just die die
wow yeah so it it everything there were
fires lit big time and i'm sorry that
you had to go through this dave but
thank you for god using you
to share with us well thank you and we
thought well we're 55 years old at the
time i was like yeah well this is never
going to happen we're too old yeah never
it's too late to start well
it's not
ever we're in our 60s now and
so it's um
you can do it
no matter what age you're at that is so
inspiring i feel like somebody out there
needs to hear that yes definitely and a
health scare that's that's quite a
wake-up call right what happened so you
read that note you got on board with fpu
what did you all do to get out of debt
what did the journey look like for you
guys well one of the hardest things we
had to do was sell the the cabin
oh
and we we still miss it but hey we can
always do a vrbo and go to that but
uh we did vrbo our cabin then we're told
we couldn't do it anymore because it was
uh against the hoa against the hoa which
they never told us when we bought the
cabin so it's like okay
so then we did uh had an rv an rv we
rented out
i tell you don't ever do that because
it's the worst thing you can ever do is
rent your rv out because people don't
care about your rv they don't care about
you i can't ruin it she wanted to push
it off
i wanted to drive into colorado and just
put in neutral and go oh
oh you just went over the cliff
all the insurance company
[Laughter]
so we did
before the pandemic we did lyft and uber
and then one
pandemic hit then we decided to switch
over to ubereats and uh they were just
sword ash wow
how does it feel now that's a that's a
lot of debt to pay off it's it was
almost um surreal
we were sitting at sonic getting a drink
and we made our last payment and i
started crying because it was like
we can't get to drink and not have to
worry you know
that it's in the budget but
it's okay
you know you're a hard drinker if you're
drinking sonic every day
oh my gosh you guys that's so fun okay
what church was this that you went
through financial peace university new
life church out of little rock it's a
greater little rock rick bazette is our
is our uh
pastor oh because yes oh really yeah
okay he's in ukraine right now yeah he's
a great guy yeah yes i met a bunch of
those guys that's awesome yeah excellent
well done y'all i'm proud of you thank
you how's it feel
awesome yeah it does this is our first
actual vacation
since we started it and we brought our
granddaughter with us and all she cared
about was hearing shopping
and
she's heard dave ramsey since she was
what seven years old and
kind of rolled her eyes and she would
say once in a while what would dave say
oh you know or what would they do you
can't do that
so yes leaving a legacy
is touching so what's next now now that
you don't have this major debt hanging
over your head well we we are like i
said we're getting closer to the age to
where we can
look at retirement but we've still got
our house that we need to pay off
and uh so we're still doing the doordash
and
uber eats and you know do instacart once
in a while
but you know i mean that's also a thing
that we can do into retirement
that we don't have to quit
and just
sit on the couch or whatever yeah but uh
and we can go and see family more
i love that i love that you've like
checked off this huge milestone and now
you're like okay we're gonna keep
pushing we're gonna keep going and yeah
i fully expect to see y'all here in a
few years
well actually we were here last year in
october and we told them we'd be back
yeah and we are so we said their very
first class in fpu that we were coming
here to do our debt free screen wow
we're honored and we made it y'all are
amazing you're heroes you're absolute
heroes well done thank you thank you i
mean you decided no matter you know
whatever the obstacle we're gonna do it
it's hard to sell the cabin it's hard to
not push the rv off a cliff it's hard to
it's hard to do this and one thing we
did or we would say like be like the
tortoise yes that was his favorite thing
so yeah i was ready to pick the tortoise
up and throw it but
i'll leave yeah there's a lot of stuff
going over the
cliff just saying
poor tortoise he's riding in the rv
way to go y'all you're amazing
absolutely amazing we've got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you that is
the next chapter in your story our
latest number one best seller you are on
your way to being millionaires i'm so
proud of you copy a total money makeover
you'll be able to give that to somebody
in one of your classes and a one-year
membership to financial peace university
you'll be able to scholarship somebody
that needs it that way and
i'm sure you'll do that while you're
leading and absolutely incredible so
thank you guys we're very very very
proud of you good good work
all right
223 000
paid off in four years in three months
making 152 000 to 178 000 tim and luanne
from little rock arkansas it's never too
late count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three
two
one we're
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's
dancing
their retirement world is completely
changed
so the work they've done in the last
four years amazing they got their life
back
sticky note
to financial peace university there you
go that's how you get the ramsey away
going this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
michael is with us in san diego hey
michael welcome to the ramsey show
hello thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up
um so i am finishing up baby step three
and i'm trying to balance between three
b and four
so i live in southern california i own
my own business and income can vary i
also my business has changed quite a bit
over the past couple years due to covid
so i haven't had a consistent kind of
business model so i'm still
fine-tuning that piece
um like i said my income can vary so i
can make either two thousand dollars a
month or fifteen thousand dollars a
month and i don't know um when i will
really have enough money for a down
payment so i can't predict whether two
years five years or anything like that
so at 35 years old i'm trying to
figure out how to balance between saving
up for a home and investing
to qualify for a mortgage you're going
to have to have a self-employed two
years of income tax returns the average
of those two years they will use to
qualify you
and so if you if the average of those
two years is three thousand dollars a
month they're going to qualify you on
that if the average of the two years is
going to be 15 000 a month they're gonna
qualify you on that so
uh that's what they're looking at
they're looking at what you're making a
year for the last two cap two tax
returns
and so what you're what you could do is
say when am i going to get
a high enough income average
across two years to qualify for a
mortgage and then you know is that going
to take three years from today it might
and during that time you can just save
like crazy um so people do
they save up for their down payment and
we're okay with any portion of this
if you're not going to put anything in
retirement and throw everything at the
down payment fund we say don't go longer
than three years doing that
but if you're going to be putting money
aside for a down payment and be putting
you know 15 torture
uh
you know but a full baby step four or 15
towards retirement of your household
income
uh then you can go as long as you want
to go
because you're saving right
and so uh you know above the 15 you're
going to save your down payment which
obviously is going to cut down on your
down payment so what'd you pay taxes on
last year
i think he was around 30
okay
all right
and this year so far i'm at 50.
um so yeah
so you're gonna have to get
this year and next year
to even come close to qualifying agreed
yes
thirty thousand on buying a house in san
diego
what do you do what is your business
so i'm a business consultant and i help
teams just quickly develop strategy so
my work was in person and then covet hit
and then everything became virtual and
so trying to transition into that and
now i do kind of a hybrid of in-person
and virtual
okay about how many hours are you
working right now
um i'd say about 40.
okay
i what i would do um are you doing a lot
of one-off fees or are you running
retainers
one office yeah that's what's killing
you i thought you were because of the
volatility you need to start talking
about taking clients that pay you
uh a guaranteed retainer for a year
and that will stabilize that will
stabilize your income and then you can
also start to layer those and
create a situation where you can work
you know 60 hours a week doing this
because you've got clients that are
coming back to you you've promised them
so many hours a month average
on something and then you've just got to
schedule them in and stay with them
because um you know
what you're doing
is an implementation thing
and following up on the implementation
and guiding them through the actual
implementation once it's decided to do
how to do it you you're getting paid for
the how to do it but the walking with
them as they do it is also a valuable
uh service that you could
meld into this and that puts you into a
retainer situation i would shift my
model if i were you
well that'll just give him so much more
money as he stabilizes his income as he
gets more consistent clients as he ups
his income he's going to have so much
more money to throw towards that down
payment and the ability to get a house
zero going if you're saving a down
payment aggressively and you're putting
real money in there which you're not at
thirty thousand you might be a fifty a
hundred thousand uh which sounds like
you're scheduled for this year give or
take uh but the uh uh
if
you're putting zero towards baby step
four you know the rule of thumb we use
is just don't go out there don't do that
for 10 years and have nothing in
retirement right you know so three years
is about a max on that give or take
something in that range and that's what
we're looking for
steve is with us in oklahoma city hi
steve how are you
hey dave hope you're doing well better
than we deserve brother what's up
um i have a
kind of a pickle i'm in
my job is offering me an opportunity to
move
to their home base in austin texas
and it's kind of putting me in a
situation i just recently bought a brand
new house first house i've ever had
it's in an area that i can afford
but the area that they want me to move
to
and actually be on site is gonna put me
in a disadvantage financially
the benefit is is i get uh better pay
more opportunity
they're gonna pay for all my expenses
but i don't know if it's a good decision
for me
or if i should just stay here
so i figured you're the smartest person
about money i know
why not ask you
you you said it's an opportunity there
is the choice you can stay where you are
right
yeah and how much of a pay increase is
it going to be to move
uh it's going to be like a 10
pay increase and then yeah what do you
mean there's no ceiling
i make 64 000 right now
i'm a single dad they want you to move
to austin texas from oklahoma city for 5
000 bucks
yeah whoopee no
okay not unless you just love austin
texas
let me make sure i i thought i heard in
your voice
you really like your life right now
i do
i thought i heard that and like this is
like
but i don't want to not do something
smart but i like it i like what i'm
doing
what are you doing in the middle of
nowhere here yeah what do you do i don't
have an opportunity to meet people i
work at home
for tech support okay all right
and you said you're a single
pay ceiling right now so if i don't do
this i i can't make any more money you
can't if you change jobs
yeah i can change jobs no
i mean you leave that company in tech
support and probably make 10 more
from where you're sitting
do you have family in the area that
you're at right now
yeah they're a couple hours away
okay are you married
no i'm single
okay i'm raising two kids on my own
how old are they
uh they're one's gonna be thirteen one's
eight
okay
so you would be on site in the office
and now you work from home
yes that's an advantage
for moving up
because you're you're present and people
see your smiling little face and you are
more likely to get noticed
and be promoted than you are sitting in
your bedroom doing tech support
um yeah that's correct it's the
disadvantage of work from home people
forget you
um you just disappear
i think they need to sweeten the package
and then i might go do it then i might
go do it and i'm going to call it an
adventure
but 5k is just uh it's not interesting
okay
so um
now the package sweetener could be
if you come down here and you do a b and
c
we're going to promote you and you'll be
making 70. but for now it's 5k
that would be a package sweetener
i want to see this upward momentum i
want to see this a path up
that's clearly defined
but 5k i'm not moving for
i've moved for 5k and a clearly defined
path up though would you yeah yeah
so yeah
austin's cost of living is different
than oklahoma city area
way different this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsaysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships
christina ellis number one best-selling
author ramsey personality is my co-host
today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money open phones a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two
five
jordan is in rochester new york to start
us off this hour hi jordan how are you
good how are you dave better than we
deserve sir how can we help
all right so i'm 21 and i just graduated
from college this may yay what's your
degree in yeah uh information systems oh
i love it you got the big job
yeah so i actually was fortunate enough
to get a job straight out of the gate so
fortunate enough for that yeah what are
you making
um a little bit over um i'm making a
hundred and fifteen thousand good more
there's some bonuses yep straight out of
college that's awesome i'm so proud of
you
thank you
yeah so my question is though i have 14
000 left in federal student loans
and i also have a brokerage account with
mutual funds that i've been contributing
to
since i was in high school
and there's 15 000 in those accounts and
i was wondering is it smarter for me to
leave that money in the accounts and set
up a payment plan to pay out those
federal student loans or should i just
pull out all the money from those mutual
funds and pay them off now
three years from now the answer
mathematically will be almost equivalent
okay okay
but
if i woke up in your shoes
and you are an impressive young man
uh thank you i i would write a check
today and be debt-free
okay
and along with that
the more important part of the
conversation is
this commitment to
get out of debt stay out of debt and
avoid debt permanently
that
process that promise to yourself
will make you wealthy
gotcha because if you don't have any
payments and you make 100 grand at 21
years old you can you can become wealthy
dude and you're gonna be a millionaire
you're gonna be a millionaire by the
time you're 30.
i'm hoping no you will be
if you do the stuff i teach you to do on
this show and and then baby have you got
a copy of baby steps millionaires
i do i've read it okay then you know you
know exactly what i'm talking about
you follow those baby steps making 115
today with the four-year degree in
information systems in a hot tech market
like we're in you're going to be making
200 by the time you're
25
and you're going to be consistently
investing and being generous and living
on a plan and being intentional and
enjoying your money but consistently
investing you're going to have serious
bank dude
i'm hoping no it's not a hope it's a
mathematical fact
jordan i just feel so much joy talking
to you to hear that you're 21 years old
you've got such a great income and
you're reading baby steps millionaires
you're in the middle of this process
this is just so exciting yeah just don't
get stupid
i'm not i'm uh you know living below my
means yeah yeah so if along with this
promise to follow the baby steps from
the
and say i'm going to avoid debt so i can
keep control of my largest wealth
building tool which is my fabulous
income
and not committed to
freaking lexus motor credit
right not committed to somebody else
not fall off the not not go be normal
or arrogant and think you're the
exception of the rule and you can beat
this or something like that just be
boring as crap on your money stuff and
just sucking it away and being generous
with it and enjoying it systematically
with detailed intentionality
like you would if you were working a
flow chart for one of your information
system situations then you're gonna
you're gonna be there dude you're gonna
be there the the you if you can just
avoid the new car panic if you can just
avoid the
the whatever
stupid things your friends get involved
in like bitcoin if you'll just go do
basic smart stuff you're going to be
unbelievably wealthy and you've cause
you've got such a freaking head start
such a good head start i love seeing
those charts when it compares you know
if somebody starts investing for
retirement at 21 versus like 45
and i mean it's just sad that a lot of
kids miss out on the opportunity for all
that compound interest i mean
you know everybody looks back and wishes
that they would have done some certain
things sooner but it's like so cool to
see that this generation is starting to
jump on these principles early and like
dave said if you can stay focused
there's going to be so much temptation
the flashy car the big house the
opportunity for a credit card like all
these temptations are going to come up
but if you can stay focused starting at
21 and push all the way through
yeah
you're on your way man you're on your
way just don't yeah
just avoid the
the temptation to look
successful don't nobody gives a crap how
you look okay
wait what you drive you know let's just
be
successful
and you know we'll worry about how you
look later
in in an instagram world you know let's
try to actually be something instead of
just look like something
uh you know the shallowness of our
current culture
um you know we have influencers who are
influencing who have never done anything
except have a big instagram account
and that's you know how how do you get
to be famous you're famous for being
famous you know in that case
yeah shoot me oh god but the uh you know
now i got a reality show but now instead
actually
just go b do the stuff and be
successful not look
right and it's like it's like what you
say like the paid off house has taken
the place of the bmw as a status symbol
of choice it's like man if you're 30
years old and you have a paid off house
and you're a baby steps millionaire
that's gonna look so much cooler than if
you're driving around in a flashy car
that you can't really afford with a big
old loan payment like that's not really
cool in the grand scheme of things like
building true wealth that lasts that is
that's cool
well done well done hunters in el paso
texas hey hunter what's up
christina my question is surrounding an
incentive we receive at work we get x
amount of stock over a three year
vesting period for employee retention
and my question basically is how that's
going to be taxed as i read about it
several sources say either capital gains
or income tax rates
but i'm trying to figure out how to
decide that and my confusion comes with
there not being an initial investment by
me how the capital gains would work i
was wondering if you could give me some
insight and
either in either case your basis is zero
so it's compensation and if you don't if
you haven't held the stock vested for at
least one year for sure it's not going
to qualify for capital gains
so if it's under 12 months it's going to
be ordinary income 100
100 of what you're selling for is going
to be taxable in either case
now whether if you've held it three
years
um is it going to qualify because it's
compensatory is it because it's
compensation is it going to qualify for
capital gains i don't know that for sure
you would need to check your tax advisor
to be sure on that i am not really great
at details on taxes i know some of the
basic stuff but something like that i
personally call my tax guy and find out
so that i don't screw it up and so i'm
not going to lie to you until you know
the answer to that but it will be one of
the other and it won't be it'll 100 be
ordinary income if it's under a year for
sure no question about that and for sure
your basis is zero so 100 of the amount
is taxable just not sure which rate
applies after one year
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis number one best-selling
author ramsey personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us america
hey parents there's a lot you can't
control you can't control inflation you
can't control the economy you're sure as
crap can't control washington dc but you
can control
how you'll teach your teens
to face life and all of those things and
the sooner they learn the better
the best thing you can teach your teen
this year is how to handle their money
the right way how to get on a budget how
to save how to spend wisely the
foundations in personal finance
homeschool curriculum
has helped millions of families teach
their kids
it'll give your teens the tools they
need to win with money
pay cash for college and stay out of
debt
it's not just another homeschool
curriculum it's completely changing how
teens think about money
permanently and then they come on the
air here and do a debt-free scream when
they're 25 years old and say my mom and
dad homeschool me and so when i married
my
spouse and they had debt we knew how to
get out of it immediately and we knew we
needed to get out of it immediately and
we knew how to do a budget they're
completely schooled up that's what this
is for
this is part of changing your family
tree is the training
to learn more go to ramseysolutions.com
homeschool ramsey solutions dot com
slash homeschool jen is in phoenix hi
jen welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
um i was in a position last year to
purchase a home but um unfortunately the
line of work that i was in um i have a
child who
you know is on the spectrum and the job
that i was working in was a child
prospective
capacity and they wanted evenings
holidays and weekends so i had to leave
that job and in the three months that it
took me to get another job
um it made better sense to sell my home
and to rent it because i didn't have the
cash flow
and i was wondering um i got the money
out of my home
um
i'm really sad that i had to tell it
anyways but i'm wondering i'm
just getting apprehensive about if i'll
ever be able to enter the market again
and exactly what i should do with the
money that i have saved because it's i
have it all sitting there when you get
back in the market when things are a
little bit more stable
what's unstable
well it's stable in in the sense that i
have a job now that that i can be a
mother and being you know working so are
they staying
is your life stable now
oh it is it just took me i knew that i
would i'm employable i'm very employable
but it just took a couple months away
today you said you were going to wait
until things were more stable but it
sounds like they are stable
well yes they are
they are i'm sorry so i'm nervous what
what is keeping you from going and
buying a house then
i well i just came out i just sold my
home and i just wanted to i don't know
with interest rates up and and
everything i don't know if i can
actually afford um
i just don't know what i can afford i
don't know what would be smart i know
waiting probably isn't
but i'm i just
i just want to make sure that i can
afford a home so you're making a whole
lot of assumptions
about everything being horrible and you
don't even know the details
no i need to sit down and i do uh
apologize i'm i just no i'm not i'm not
i'm not calling you out i just hear a
lot of anxiety in your voice
i i i even wonder
my home represented more than forty
percent of my take home and i thought
about um renting the one that i had no
you did the right thing you did the
right thing you were you were trying you
listen here's what you chose here's what
i heard
you chose taking care of your kid
yeah
which makes you like the best mom in the
world
in the world the the
owning a home does not make you the best
mom in the world
you can get another house there's a
freaking house on every corner you just
got one kid though
yeah that's true you made the right
choice
yeah you were in the situation you were
in with the information you had you made
the best decision you could make at the
time right no i did thank you so quit
beating yourself up you're an awesome
mom
thank you
okay
let's breathe in and let's put all of
that in the rearview mirror
now let's look at the windshield
okay okay
you now have a stable situation where
you can take care of the kid how much
money you got in the bank from the sale
of the house
about 70 000. okay
nothing's on fire
you don't have to rush out and do
anything
but let's just begin the process
of learning about what it is you can
afford
at 25 of your take-home pay with 70 000
down on a 15-year fixed-rate mortgage
and begin to look at those types of
houses
and go i don't really want to buy one of
those i think i'll save a little while
before and add some to the 70 before i
do that that's okay but we're not going
to sit around and
watch the news
and by the way interest rates went down
this week
oh
okay i'm just i'm traumatizing myself by
saying that exactly yeah you're
catastrophizing
so and that's okay i mean you've been
through you've been through a lot you
had a lot of stress and i what i'm what
i want you to do is is
gain some peace from where you're
sitting today and and from the fact that
you did make good decisions
and now let's just ease back towards the
right direction of home ownership again
and uh but we don't have to thrash
around and say oh we can't do it because
the interest rates are oh we better do
it because we'll never get in if we
don't rush over there and get something
right now and just
calm
sorry
and let's just steady
yeah facts are your friends i love that
getting getting your plan together
figuring out what you can actually
afford laying everything out on paper on
purpose so that you can see clearly not
just feel that anxiety and just live
there but i'm with dave you're a great
mom you made the right decision for your
family um one question i have is are you
still in the same job or do you still
have a pretty unstable schedule with
evenings and weekends and
nights no i'm i'm looking for um i'm in
the same capacity but i'm in a job that
doesn't require me i can actually work
from home in this job that the other job
i had to be like out in
how much do you mean
about 50.
okay
how old are you i'm in my late 40s okay
how old your baby
she's 12 this year okay good
well i think that's even a breathing
point you're probably feeling some of
the fear from just the last time you
owned a home and you were in that
situation where things felt out of
control and you know you're working the
weekends it's difficult balancing a
family and even
breathing and letting that go and just
kind of refocusing as you think about
buying another house you know and just
letting go of some of that stress and
difficulty from the last time this is a
new situation you're in a totally
different position
your baby's taken care of you're in a
good spot to move forward yeah just
because the last guy you dated as a jerk
doesn't mean the next one has to be
i've been it in years no no i'm talking
about the last house didn't work because
you bought too much house and it was an
unstable job situation so the new house
doesn't have to be a jerk it can be it'd
be okay right
you said it definitely and i guess what
i'm wondering is i i don't mind saving i
mean my job i can't whether i like it or
not they're putting 12 away from me of
my salary and i think they're matching
it so i can't even touch that so i'm
whether i want to save retirement right
now i'm saving it away all right well
you're you're moving in the right
direction you got everything going so
what i would tell you to do is if you're
debt free let's hold that 70 000 and
begin to add to it get in touch with uh
one of the uh endorsed local providers
one of the ramsey trusted real estate
agents in your area
sit down with them and say
listen i'm a little scared and freaked
out because
i bought too much house last time and it
scared me and i had to get out of it i
don't want to do that again and so i
need to get start gathering information
to help me make a calm
wise decision teach me
help me show me the market and let's
begin to work our way through that and
they will gently gradually slowly
show you and you you'll get your
confidence based on the new knowledge
you start gathering from this elp with
the heart of a teacher well i think
that's good for anyone sitting on the
sidelines of the real estate market
right now because the reality is
every day there's a new news article out
that sounds scary and there's a million
different opinions and there's a lot of
fear you know you have a very legitimate
situation where you know you had some
family things and too much house that
caused fear now but there's a lot of
people feeling fear for a lot of reasons
so sit down figure out the facts talk to
a professional who knows what they're
doing and can bring peace yeah
when you're feeling all hyped up folks
the lonely talks about this all the time
facts are your friends
no one makes good decisions when they're
afraid
greedy or drunk
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsay personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsay show in
the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage kyle and trisha are with
us hey guys how are you hi dave hi dave
welcome welcome where do you live oxford
indiana cool welcome to nashville we're
glad you're here thank you and how much
debt did you pay off 433 000
all right how long did this take seven
and a half years
and your range of income during that
time started about 36 000 and just now
went to about 160.
well there's a jump
okay and what do y'all do for a living
now um i'm a veterinarian and i own my
own practice
and i own a welding business
welder and fabricator okay
so i'm guessing you came out of vet
school and that's where some of this
additional jump in income came from it
did um and then it went back down
when i quit my first job and then it
went back up slowly yeah as i built the
business okay all right very good very
good
so uh
433 000 worth of vet school bills a lot
of it yeah is about 230 000 of student
loan debt um i had a really pretty f-350
platinum
truck in there the good good yeah large
animal huh
all right with a vet box
[Music]
i looked really good yeah
i don't look that good now
now you just make money oh well yeah
um but credit cards um but yeah a lot of
student loan debt y'all are fun good
very cool okay so what happened seven
and a half years ago got you started on
this whole ramsey way so
it actually started back when i was in
undergrad
my dad works for a new course deal and
they put all of their employees through
uh financial piece when you were a
little kid i was um in undergrad so
it was at the holiday inn and it was the
13-week course yeah so i drove down from
purdue and went to every lesson and i
loved it but i had no income no bills i
didn't know how it could apply to me at
that point but i always kept a 500
emergency fund through college
um but i had big dreams of going to vet
school i'd wanted to be a vet since i
was four
and um it cost a lot of money to do that
it does and um we got it's as expensive
as med school it is it is and so we got
deep in deep in debt um and i kind of
woke up again as a third year and
realized oh my gosh like what are we
gonna do and so our good friends matt
and sarah was
sarah was also a third year and so we
took fpu again as married couple um and
i vowed then like okay we're going to do
this
but then i graduated
and i might have got a little doc itis
and that's when i bought the truck
and so
it was when i quit my first job and
decided that i wanted to live
differently and practice medicine
differently that i really buckled down
and said no this is it we're done and
that was seven and a half years ago so
you got your own practice now i do we
sold our first home
and lived in a rental and now we live in
the practice oh wow so we built from the
ground up um
i was a year out of vet school when i
quit my first job
i had eight clients in my truck
and we built the
building five years ago okay wow
that's a lot of debt to pay off in seven
and a half years and in that income
range what did this journey look like
for y'all yeah so it was a lot um but
one key point that i wanted to point out
with you was that we i was fortunate in
2016 to apply for the veterinary medical
loan repayment program
in our area there's eight districts in
indiana
and
we i serve a low
a population for rural practitioners
and so i was awarded 75 000 uh through
the usda of grant money um and then i
actually got that again in 2021. wow wow
so 150 of this came from grant money
yeah
yeah so i was asked to um be on the
board to select the next
award-winning winners and then i was
like but i still have student loan debt
can i can i apply again and i did so
three times no just twice oh that was
the second time yeah
i thought she just keeps going back
it's awesome
yeah very cool and kyle you've had your
business the whole time
yeah about 10 years uh
yeah i've been welding and
plugging away so good good
did y'all do anything unusual to get out
of debt did you
you know do any side hustles or you know
just get super tight with a budget what
was like the hardest part most
interesting part to y'all
i think living in the practice has been
the most interesting i mean financially
it's helped us tremendously
but when we built the practice i wasn't
going to have any children and now i
have two
and you all still live there yeah we
have a two bedroom it's about a thousand
square foot that is cool that we live in
so large animal small animal boat i do
both okay yep all right very cool and
you've got a welding shop or you just do
on-site work yeah i've got a shop and a
truck i go and do mobile work um there's
a shop there at the same site uh no it's
off the road a little bit okay but um
but yeah
you know i've had other jobs along the
way too you just work as much as you can
and um for me staying humble and
what we've got to work with um was a big
deal yeah so for the people who think it
can't be done people who are sitting
with 4000
thousand dollars in debt what would you
tell them
contentment
it's huge um
you know when i
when i graduated and bought the truck
that's what i thought a vet
did i thought that's what i was supposed
to do
um
and
when i sold that truck
for my boys
and knowing that we could have more
that's when it changed and we were
paying off 80 000 plus a year at that
point um you know i still show up to
farm calls and they ask where the
veterinarian is
because i drive not a nice truck now um
but you know i'm still the veterinarian
that i was supposed to be you're more
now yes yes because you can actually
concentrate on the animal instead of the
i can practice
i want to practice
for sure when you're walking examples of
that contentment like to live in the
practice to give up the truck to be
content that way that's that's
impressive that's awesome it's powerful
and got great next chapters coming i
mean the next the next five years gonna
be amazing
yeah because um yeah the um
i can see it on you
i can see the the peace on you
and um what folks don't realize running
a business is that's unbelievably
attractive yeah and so the number of
people that are going to come and do
business with both of you because you
don't have to
and um
that's uh it's a different world it's a
different place to be well done y'all
i'm very proud of you you're incredible
you're an incredible young couple who
are your biggest cheerleaders in the
process
oh i mean each other for sure and our
parents um
and
my employees they have to listen to you
constantly
i do surgery to you i do all my office
work to the show
um
she does it's on all the time
i'm sorry kyle
yeah
some somewhere there's a hound dog that
woke up out of anesthesia and is now out
of debt
yeah but you know they're all cheering
us on and um you know i hope that we've
maybe helped a few along the way as well
um and then i've been fortunate to lead
fpu um i'm coming up on starting my
sixth class oh wow here next week and so
um you know all of them have been
very much part of our journey well thank
you for doing that it's very rewarding
the the biggest thing that i guess i'm
walking other than being debt-free
is feeling my money i love that um
when i walk into a gas station i've got
i'm using cash
and i appreciate you teaching me that
because
man you can spend a lot of money sure
just a couple times of the gas station
let's bring the boys up here and
introduce them what are their names and
ages
uh so case is five
and kane just turned three all right we
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you total money makeover and a
financial peace membership kyle tricia
casey kane from indiana 433 000 paid off
in seven and a half years making 36 to
160 very impressive count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream three two
[Applause]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day galatians 5 13
for you were called to freedom brothers
only do not use your freedom as an
opportunity for the flesh but through
love serve one another
audrey hepburn said as you grow older
you will discover that you have two
hands one for helping yourself and the
other for helping others
very good
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today john is with us john is in
san antonio texas hey john what's
up hey dave and uh christina um just had
a quick question for you all i'm a
master financial coach on baby step four
been following you and your program for
uh gosh over five years
i switched careers about almost two
years ago to become an insurance agent
and that job went
full-time
remote
got engaged
to a girl who lives in mexico
and have been spending a lot of time
between texas and working in mexico and
um i just wanted to see your thoughts
i've been seeing this opportunity and
you know moving away from from
california after being there for so many
years
because of the expense um i've been
seeing that you know you can have a
pretty good life like in in a safe part
of mexico and even the beach life and
things like that and i've been thinking
about you know maybe doing that in the
uh you know going forward here one day
as kind of like a more permanent move
and just wonder your thoughts on that
your reason for doing this is that your
girlfriend is there
no well
um we're going to be we're going through
the immigration process and she's going
to be having to live in the u.s under
greek heart before
she can become a u.s citizen but then
once she does that my real motivation
is because of
the
the us dollars of income and spending
pesos which
you know pretty much takes you you know
takes you a lot further right it takes
your money a lot further
um
no i mean it converts and then
it's a bazillion pesos you know peso's
about a nickel right now
and um
so it just takes a lot of pesos to get
you know 20 of them to get to a dollar
right
still yeah yeah exactly and my my well
it's still a 200
hotel room and it's still the equivalent
of 200 in pesos it's not like
because the peso is less that the hotel
room is 120th it's still there
right like like for example my my fiance
has a two bedroom um apartment for 500 a
month you know and like can you you know
in a great area you know that's
considered like you know the rich part
of town here yeah well i mean the cost
of living in general in mexico is there
but it's not because of the conversion
of pesos it's just the cost of living is
lower um and in many cases the standard
of living is considerably lower but not
every case
i love mexico i um
and and honestly i love mexican people
they're some of the sweetest people on
the planet i just i i thoroughly enjoy
traveling there uh so i'm a fan
in that regard um i i you know and if
you're a young guy getting married and
you you want to call that i i
would i expatriate to mexico no i would
not
but would i live there for a while as an
adventure with your new bride and say
we're gonna live here for four or five
years and just have that part of our
adventure and then we might move back to
texas but you don't have to take the us
off the table
and it's certainly not a statement that
the us is going down the toilet because
you want to do that it's just like hey
man i could go down and live on the
beach and it doesn't cost a lot and
we're young and married and this sounds
like a fun
portion of our life let's go do that
it's like some kid backpacking europe
for two years after they get out of
college or something that's cool go do
it that's great you know that's fine
but um
but i wouldn't say that this is like a
permanent thing or a policy decision or
everyone ought to do it or something
like that it's just like you're just
kind of on an adventure you're going to
go surf a little
i'm assuming you can run your business
from there right
i'm working for an employer and my small
small agency and they uh they don't have
a problem with me doing this
um i mean i've been doing it for about
seven eight months now off and on and
the internet's great and you know it's
safe where i'm at and you know and you
know that's like the fourth time you've
said it it's safe where i am
so which means which is is an indication
that you do understand the truth it's
not all safe
so um yeah law and order is a problem
yeah i'm with dave i think if this is
something that you want to do because
it's fun it's something that you want to
do to be
near your future wife's family if this
is something you want to do because it's
a joy and an adventure that sounds
awesome but if it's out of fear that
you're you know not going to have enough
money here in the u.s if it's something
that's kind of just a negative thing
where it's like you're going to mexico
to try to save money but you know
there's fear around money here and does
it convert like that that kind of sounds
like a bummer i think that in the career
that you're in you can make enough money
to have a great life here in the states
um
but again if it's exciting then then
more power to you living on the beach i
think that's awesome yeah have some fun
with it all right mike is with us mike
is in phoenix arizona hey mike what's up
hey thanks for taking my call sure how
can we help
um i started watching uh your your show
and listening to your show about five
years ago and it was then i decided to
get serious about paying debt so thank
you very much for that thank you um
since then i've paid about 382 thousand
dollars in debt and all i have left is
the mortgage yay good job yeah
so after paying about 150 000 towards
the mortgage and then refinancing at a
lower rate i kind of fell off the
bandwagon of the 15 investing and
tackling the mortgage
and then instead opted to save
approximately 60 percent of my income
for the last two years so i stopped
heavily going after the mortgage
so on short notice i got voted for a job
and in two weeks i'm going to close on a
new house for 415 000
and because of such short notice i
didn't have enough cash for down payment
so i took a brokerage loan of 80 000 for
the down payment
i plan to keep my previous primary
residence as a rental
so all this has gotten me focused on
paying back debt and i'm planning to be
100 debt free in six years
the question i have is i know you
recommend the smallest balance first
because of behavior modification reasons
but does that same principle apply to
mortgage debt too
no
but if i'm in your shoes i'm not going
to have that problem i wouldn't keep
that other house
you're in debt up your eyeballs man you
just fell completely off the wagon and
rolled down the road
yeah i didn't
yeah and you went to a brokerage account
for a down payment you're curling with
two hairs i have left
unbelievable man you are really playing
it
so now i'm
sell the other house and get this mess
cleaned up you made
would it change anything if you know my
mortgage payment on that house is three
hundred and fifty dollars a month but it
rents for three thousand nope and it
could be additional income nope
because you know how you bought that
rental property that has this great cash
flow
because you borrowed against your
current residence you didn't affect you
didn't actually but on your balance
sheet you did
because since you didn't put down all of
that equity on this current house you're
up to your data up your eyeballs and
debt on this current house so it has the
same effect of hey i had a house almost
paid off and i just went and borrowed on
it to buy a rental and now i'm smiling
because the rental cash flows nope
no sales
hey you do whatever you want to do but
i'm telling you the shortest distance
between where you are and wealthy
is not leveraging your personal
residence up to your eyeballs tone or
rental property the cash flows it's not
you've added so much risk to your life
um well the renter is going to pay it
the renters don't always pay
well you know you know you know what
happened during the pandemic it's called
a moratorium on eviction and so they sat
there on their butts and didn't pay you
a dime
because you couldn't legally do anything
about it
and they're just sitting over there
grinning living in your house for free
there went your cash flow no no way dude
don't need the risk
don't need the risk you can do whatever
you want to do but i think 10 years from
today you're going to regret this move
versus if you get completely clear
housing everything and then start
investing on the side and save up and
pay cash for your rental that's what i
would do
it's going to feel so much better that
way like this this way sounds very
stressful and i know that deep down it
feels that way yeah mike the problem
with our stuff is you can't go through
it like it's a buffet and just pick some
of the stuff off the buffet you kind of
got to do the whole thing or it doesn't
work
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books good job christina good job
austin and will and zach and
andrew and james i am dave ramsey your
host we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone
it's the only place to listen to the
entire back catalog of episodes download
the ramsey network app in your favorite
app store today
[Music]
you